هذه اخر منطقه وصلت اليها القوات الروسيه
سابقا والتي تبعد عن العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف قرابه الثلاثين كيلومترا بعد انسحابها
واستهداف القوات الاوكرانيه ومعطلات
الجنود ودبابات من نوع تي 72 و تي 80
وسائل الاعلام دوليه تتحدث بان روسيا خسرت
حتى هذه اللحظه مئات الدبابات
بدات روسيا انا ذاك هجومها من عده محاور
بهدف اضعاف القدرات الدفاعيه لخصمهم قسما
على الارض واستحدافا من الجو وتدميرا
للبنيه التحتيه عبر صواريخها تمهيدا لتقدم
طوابير قواتها
السريعه اتجاهها كيف
توقفت وبدا الامر لها صدمه عندما واجهت
المقاومه الاخرانيه بدعم الامدادات
العسكريه الغربيه
الى الانسحاب
الحرب حتى الان هي حرب كلاسيكيه تقليديه
بين الدولتين سواء ما تلقته روسيا من
هجمات سبرانيه بشكل اقل من قبل تحالف
المتطوعين الدوليين الذين وصفوا بانهم
متعاطفون مع اوكرانيا لا اكثر لقناتيه
العربيه والحدثان الصفيان كيف